wenn dieses fenster auf millionen
iphones auftaucht wird facebook boss
mark zuckerberg wohl richtig facebook
bittet um erlaubnis seine aktivitäten in
ebbs und auf websites andere unternehmen
zu erfassen app tracking ablehnen
checking erlauben mit einem neuen update
fragen iphones jetzt beim öffnen von
apps auf trekking zugelassen werden soll
für mich als user klingt das erst mal
super ich muss mich nicht mehr mühselig
durch irgendwelche
datenschutz-einstellungen willen nein
ich werde von der app gefragt ob ich
tracking zu lassen möchte oder eben
nicht dahinter steckt ein streit
zwischen facebook chef mark zuckerberg
und apple chef tim cook der jetzt offen
entbrannt ist wenn ein unternehmen auf
der irreführung von nutzern über die
ausbildung von daten auf
wahlmöglichkeiten aufgebaut ist die gar
keine sind verdient es nicht unser logo
es verdient eine reform sagen dass sie
dies tun um den menschen zu helfen aber
diese schritte folgen eindeutig ihren
wettbewerbsinteressen zwei der
mächtigsten männer der welt wollen jetzt
also über die zukunft unserer daten
entscheiden
ich habe mir einige fragen gestellt als
ich zum ersten mal von diesem update
gehört habe zuerst mal was bedeutet das
jetzt eigentlich für mich als user was
für ein streit zwischen facebook und
apple steckt da dahinter die ernst meint
apple es mit dem datenschutz und können
sich den datenschutz bald nur noch leute
leisten die sich ein iphone kaufen
können oder die bei apple kaufen möchte
diese fragen werde ich versuchen in
diesem video zu beantworten
am anfang von meiner recherche habe ich
mich direkt gefragt was bedeutet dieses
update jetzt eigentlich für mich als
user dazu müssen wir uns erstmal
anschauen was aktuell im hintergrund mit
unseren daten passiert markus beckedahl
journalist und netzaktivist erklärt das
so ich surfe auf eine seite wie
youtube.com youtube denkt die person
kenne ich die war ja gestern schon da
außerdem unsere werbepartner partner von
der anderen seite kann mir be- teilen
der bar auch schon dort und dort und die
person könnte über 40 seien männlich
könnte sich die und die produkte
interessieren
hallo werbemarkt wir haben hier diese
person die gerade vorbeikommt
wer bietet den am meisten dafür dass wir
eure werbung jetzt ihm anzeigen mit dem
neuen update könnte sich das ändern
aber was genau mit dem update fragen
sich jetzt nicht nur die app von
facebook sondern auch die von insta und
andere ob sie meine aktivitäten in ebbs
und auf webseiten anderer unternehmen
erfassen dürfen und ich kann jetzt
einfach ablehnen wenn ich das nicht will
tracking transparency and apple das kurz
etc
klingt erstmal praktisch für mich aber
wie sah das dann davor aus ich weiß gar
nicht habe ich es abgeschaltet oder
nicht weißt du wo ich das nachschauen
kann
das war heute ich weiter ich muss ja
auch jedes mal durchblicken ob sozusagen
unter datenschutz wahrscheinlich also in
den einstellungen unter datenschutz und
dann unter tracking apps erlauben
tracking anzufordern
kann es sein dass es das ja das ist bei
mir noch an der bei mir so ich habe das
dann ganz schnell abgeschaltet aber
genau darauf dass man eben das nicht so
leicht findet darauf haben facebook und
andere web unternehmen gesetzt mit dem
update fürchtet facebook jetzt
milliardenverluste und facebook gründer
mark zuckerberg scheint richtig sauer zu
sein auf apple-chef tim cook beim thema
datenschutz brodelt es schon länger
zwischen den beiden tech giganten dieses
update jetzt aber das ist eine
kampfansage die auch auswirkungen auf
uns user haben wird welche dazu später
mehr zu erstmal müssen wir uns anschauen
warum streiten sich facebook und apple
auf der einen seite in diesem kampf
steht apple und seinen chef tim cook das
unternehmen gibt sich als beschützer der
privatsphäre im digitalen raum und hat
erkannt dass sich das auch ganz gut
verkaufen lässt
immer wieder kritisiert tim cook
facebook öffentlich ohne dabei den namen
des unternehmens sondern auf der anderen
seite facebook und sein unternehmenschef
mark zuckerberg das neue apple update
bedroht das geschäftsmodell von facebook
instagram whatsapp nämlich daten sammeln
auf grundlage davon kann personalisierte
werbung verkauft werden
apple verkauft kontinents
nutzerfreundlichkeit ein gutes gefühl
bei der nutzung von computern und
computertechnologien während facebook
wiederum ein werbeunternehmen des und
das interesse von facebook ist möglichst
viele daten zu sammeln mit dem ziel
personalisierte werbung zu verkaufen und
darüber geld zu verdienen und das
kollidiert halt gerade sozusagen die
unterschiedlichen geschäftsinteressen
die da aufeinanderprallen führt zu einem
kampf der giganten wo im idealfall wir
nutzerin irgendwann als die gewinner
hervorgehen bei bisher waren eigentlich
immer die looser wenn es um
transparentes heimliches tracking auch
die beiden chefs sind grundverschieden
mark zuckerberg 36 hat facebook
gegründet und er hat mal gesagt dass
menschen immer mehr daten über sich
teilen das sei eine neue soziale norm
tim cook ist 60 war stellvertreter von
steve jobs und es nach seinem tod
geworden er ist laut wall street journal
ein sehr privater mensch anfangs sahen
sich die beiden firmenchefs noch als
partner
obwohl damals die geschäftsmodelle schon
sehr unterschiedlich waren spätestens
2018 ist der streit dann aber öffentlich
entbrannt facebook stand damals wegen
seiner daten sammelt praktiken in
cambridge analytiker skandal unter druck
und tim cook wurde damals in einem
fernseh interview gefragt was er denn
machen würde wenn er an mark zuckerberg
stelle wäre seine antwort ich wäre nicht
in der situation mark zuckerberg scheint
das richtig getroffen zu haben
laut wall street journal sóller
zuspitzen managerinnen und managern
gesagt haben wir müssen apple schmerzen
zufügen
facebook möchte sich zu diesem zitat uns
gegenüber nicht äußern
es gehe nicht um zwei unternehmen dabei
sondern um die zukunft des freien
internets apple hat in letzter zeit
jedenfalls einige neue datenschutz
features entwickelt und das thema für
sich entdeckt apple hatte in den letzten
zwei drei jahren erkannt dass man sich
abgrenzen kann von anderen unternehmen
wie google und facebook in dem man auf
datenschutz setzt das man auch
gleichzeitig den vorteil hat quasi über
datenschutz über privatsphäre werte zu
vertreten und gleichzeitig sich
abzugrenzen von diesen anderen
unternehmen weil ein fachunternehmen
alles ausnutzen was technisch geht sich
teilweise nicht an der recht halten und
apple hat er gedacht so hey wir können
zusätzlich zu unserem lebensgefühl noch
diesen wert verkaufen dass man sich
sicher fühlen kann das ja wir auch für
datenschutz für privatsphäre stehen und
gleichzeitig unseren konkurrenten
irgendwie gegen die füße treten und
sagen hey wir sind besser als ihr seit
kurzem wird im app store aufgelistet
welche daten eine app sammelt und apple
wird mit spots wie diesen
ab heute 18 zur scheidung von welt nur
aufgerufen ich habe heute acht seiten zu
scheidungsanwälten aufgerufen
[Musik]
mit der ankündigung der app tracking
transparency ist der streit jetzt
endgültig eskaliert
auf twitter schrieb apple chef tim cook
wir glauben dass nutzer die wahl haben
sollten welche daten über sie gesammelt
werden und wie sie verwendet werden
facebook kann weiterhin benutzer über
apps und websites wie zuvor verfolgen
tracking transparency in ios 14 wird nur
verlangen dass sie dafür um erlaubnis
fragen
facebook hofft währenddessen sturm gegen
die neue funktion gibt sich als kämpfer
für das freie internet und argumentiert
millionen von kleinen unternehmen seien
auf die personalisierten anzeigen
angewiesen es werde gerade sie hart
treffen
facebook hat sogar eine kampagnen
website eingerichtet auf der
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer sich
gegen das apple update richten sollen
ich weiß wirklich nicht was wir machen
werden ich weiß nicht wo kleine
unternehmen sein werden denn es wird uns
umbringen
kleine unternehmen würden durch das
update weniger umsatz machen
argumentiert facebook ann katrin riedel
glaubt das nicht sie ist vorsitzende des
netzpolitischen vereins not ev und in
der fdp das ist bullshit was facebook da
sagt also die benutzten jetzt kleine
unternehmen haben wir auch angestiftet
so erhebt eure stimme gegen apple
geschäft kaputt das ist totaler quatsch
bei facebook ja auch immer suggeriert
man würde genau die leute erreichen die
man erreichen möchte aber ob man das
wirklich tut weiß man da hat sich
facebook auch sehr die daten
herausgepickt die ihm gepasst haben ihre
argumentation zu behaupten
kleinunternehmen würden da zugrunde
gehen und da fahren sie ganz schöne
kampagne auf dem rücken von den kleinen
unternehmen die übrigens ja auch nicht
nur kleinunternehmer sind sondern das
sind auch bürgerin die auf privatsphäre
haben aber das darf natürlich nicht
vergessen nicht für kleine unternehmen
vor allem für facebook geht es hier um
milliarden und das update lässt in der
gesamten werbebranche panik aus große
verlage fürchten folgen
protestieren dagegen aber ohne facebook
zu nennen schießt tim cook in einer
online rede im februar weiter gegen das
unternehmen ist business wenn
unternehmen auf der irreführung von
nutzern über die ausbildung von daten
auf wahlmöglichkeiten aufgebaut ist die
gar keine sind
er verdient es nicht unser lob es
verdient eine reform mark zuckerberg
hält bei der vorstellung der
quartalszahlen dagegen eher glaubt apple
geht es vor allem um
wettbewerbsinteressen beim datenschutz
view ich möchte betonen dass die apple
zunehmend als einen unserer größten
konkurrenten sehen apple mag sagen dass
sie dies tun um den menschen zu helfen
aber diese schritte folgen eindeutig
ihren wettbewerbsinteressen ich denke es
ist wichtig dass die menschen diese
dynamik verstehen in dir und andere
werden in absehbarer zeit damit
konfrontiert sein
im märz hat zuckerberg seine scharfe
rhetorik gegenüber dem update verändert
facebook selbst könnte danach sogar in
einer noch stärkeren situation sein
sagte er bei clubhouse mit eigenen shops
hat sich facebook für das update von
apple gerüstet bei dem ganzen streit
stellt sich jetzt natürlich die frage
wie ernst meint apple es mit dem
datenschutz so ganz konsequent ist apple
da auch noch nicht das zeigt sich zum
beispiel wenn man apples browser safari
öffnet standardsuchmaschine ist
ausgerechnet google ein konzern der
massig geld mit daten sammeln verdient
dafür dass google standardsuchmaschine
ist zahlt der mutterkonzern jährlich
mehrere milliarden an apple
und noch etwas macht skeptisch wir haben
ja einen kampf der giganten und apple
ist ein bisschen cooler aber jetzt auch
nicht so die coolsten weil natürlich hat
apple auch interesse möglicherweise
selbst in den werbemarkt kleiner
einzusteigen als zusatz geschenkt und
das wird natürlich apple von facebook
vorgeworfen dass man halt die eigenen
produkte bevorzugen würde
apples eigene werbenetzwerken nicht erst
wie itunes und apple books sollen von
der regelung nicht betroffen sein
damit zeigt sich wie apple auch seine
marktmacht nutzt apple ist halt ein
riesen gatekeeper also ich kann wenn ich
ein iphone habe nur über den app store
runterladen ich habe keine andere
möglichkeit in anderen store zu benutzen
das heißt unternehmen sind auf apple
angewiesen und apple kann diktieren wie
es zu laufen hat also das tut sie auch
jetzt mit dem privacy einstellungen die
ich persönlich sehr gut finde finde es
aber schwierig dass ein unternehmen
bestimmt was richtig ist und was falsch
und apple kann natürlich immer auch
entscheiden wie hoch soll die provision
sein weil die unternehmen da er weniger
diese darauf angewiesen im app store
gelistet zu werden
welche folgen hat das jetzt für uns user
gibt's privatsphäre bald nur noch für
leute die sich ein iphone leisten können
oder wollen wird datenschutz damit zum
luxusgut die überwiegende zahl der
deutschen hat schließlich kein iphone
sondern googles android und das ist ja
auch so eine prinzipien sache für manche
sogar ein glaubenskrieg jetzt also auch
beim datenschutz mit dem neuen update
könnten sich außerdem manche app
anbieter entscheiden von werbung auf
bezahlmodelle wie in app käufe
umzusteigen
auch das könnte es teurer machen
entsteht also so eine art
zweiklassengesellschaft beim datenschutz
ja wir sehen schon seit jahren dass
datenschutz leider bis hin zum luxusgut
wird das ist aber auch ein versagen der
politik die halt beispielsweise durch
klare vorgaben wie
datenschutzfreundlichen
grundeinstellungen regulativ rein gehen
könnte und sagen könnte das gilt jetzt
für alle betreiber und so haben wir die
situation dass apple sich hinstellt und
wahrscheinlich genau ausgerechnet hat
sozusagen was es ihnen bringt auch ein
marketing an image an vertrauen in die
marke wenn sie halt einfach mal diesen
schalter umlegen und dass wir dann
gleichzeitig noch als benefit ihren
konkurrenten ja teil des
geschäftsmodells wegnehmen können oder
schwer machen können auf iphones gibt es
also mehr datenschutz
auf android-geräten erstmal nicht hätte
das nicht die politik einheitlich regeln
können
ja sagt auch katrin riedel der
gesetzgeber muss denen die vorgaben
geben nicht nur weil ich der meinung bin
solche entscheidungen müssen eben von
demokratischen regierungen getroffen
werden weil ich möchte nicht dass
konzerne entscheiden was geht und was
geht nicht wir könnten uns ja auch ganz
anders machen und sagen wir wollen jetzt
alle möglichen daten sammeln ja das darf
dann liegen die müssen sich eben
regulierung beugen und ich würde mir
wünschen dass der gesetzgeber deutlich
ist das ist nicht apple ist die da die
nächsten schritt gehen sondern der
gesetzgeber
und damit das sind für alle geld wir
haben also gelernt facebooks und es
geschäftsmodelle sind zwei sehr
unterschiedliche und sie passen immer
weniger zusammen facebook geht es vor
allem darum daten zu sammeln die basis
um damit werbung zu verkaufen
apple möchte vor allem seine hardware
verkaufen und der datenschutz ist da ein
gutes verkaufsargument wie dieser
machtkampf am ende ausgeht das wird sich
vielleicht erst in einigen jahren zeigen
gerichte und kartellbehörden könnten das
entscheiden
facebook soll selbst schon eine klage
vorbereiten
[Musik]
was meint ihr ist dass apple update ein
guter schritt in die richtige richtung
oder er scheinheilig schreibt sie uns in
die kommentare
und hier haben wir euch noch zwei videos
zu anderen texten verlinkt